we're here at the hot guys judge other
hot guys because we're too hot guys I'm
pretty comfortable with my sexuality I'm
like weirdly excited about this he
actually looks better now than he did as
Uncle Jesse
he's cluded and he's like a house
husband hot yeah totally good dill
he is a Greek god ah I go hot without
even looking to rest the pile hottest in
the pile
I don't know I don't I don't know how
hot I think he is I I think Fassbender
is an absolutely gorgeous Irish man hell
no it looks like a chemistry teacher
yeah I think he could come at me with
like an Alaskan pickaxe and I'd still be
like oh you're gorgeous
I got a say yes on Fassbender I think
he's a great looking man alright yeah no
he's not hot guy he's immensely talented
he's a cool looking guy he's just inked
charming funny he's not hot but I mean
he's got a great body if he was hot on
top of hot not hot
that's his Blake Griffin is not hot
don't even say he's not hot guys got
swag and guys got flow and guys got
vulnerability and it's wrong look away
and then look back at him like it's the
first time you've seen Jake I see an
average guy starting from the bottom in
Canada is still above starting from the
bottom everywhere else great Hobbit and
Blake Griffin yeah JT is so talented it
makes you a little bit yeah he's one of
these guys that I'm like oh God he does
have it all he must have the tiniest
little weeny forehead solid forehead
brows Rick Brown fleek like you can't
have everything it takes to be a man and
also like also get a gigantic penis he's
out trying to bride at her own wedding
nope you think Radcliffe is hot he's a
boy
dude this wasn't the hobbit right Daniel
Radcliffe was not pabich no okay Blake
no probably runner-up for The Hobbit
there Daniel Radcliffe's eyes are dreamy
I'm gonna say it they're dreamy there I
won't fight people over this like he's
not hot he's the kind of guy if he
wasn't famous that you'd be like why all
the girls like it I don't think I would
feel safe in Radcliffe's arms not hot
I feel like this dude could could like
snuggle me he could solve a crime he's
got a great jaw
he's got like it's got that face is an
oval and I feel like if he did something
wrong he'd come at you with like a stern
this but like an acceptance he's solid I
think that's the best way saying he's
just sobbing he's not hot
Idris Nova Express nah
I'm gonna say no I'm gonna say yes and
you're crazy he's cute but he's not such
yet look into his eyes because that's
how they get you this guy grew into his
bondage yeah he earned it he earned it
so I'm gonna I'm gonna say yes on the
batch Liam yeah Chris Chris Hemsworth
yeah his Thormann and he didn't date
Miley Cyrus liam is hotter
I think Casey is a more nuanced hot then
the glasses that you're not wearing
right now like Casey's here
Casey's here Ben's up here Ben's up here
my problem is there's a bit of false
bravado because he's like I started from
the bottom now I'm here but you didn't
start from the bottom you started from
Degrassi right which in a lot of TV is
the bottom